hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now there
have been some changes that I will catch
you up on and I'm a little bit peeved
because I actually just finished
recording an episode only to discover
the horror that is a corrupted recording
file but that doesn't matter it's okay
I'm not mad it's fine whatever it's fine
it's cool I'm fine
it's whatever so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna catch you up on all the
changes that I've made thus far and also
reintroduce three new members of the
locker crew first up is urban streets
who said if you're looking for diamond
go to the place where the membrane trees
are it's kind of risky but it's worth it
if you want the laser cutter material
just make sure you have a lot of
batteries for your si glide well urban
streets I don't need a see guide anymore
I've got a seamoth I haven't named it
bubble butt yet but that's because I
don't have a moon pool but that's okay
next up is Michael atlas who said mark
there's a [ __ ] it's night of course it's
night why would anything be agreeable
for a said there's a big-ass temple on
one of the islands and I actually went
to the second island in the failed
episode that the never-before-seen
episode and I couldn't find any sort of
alien temple so unless there's another
island somewhere I'll show you guys I'm
not goofing yeah so unless there's a new
island somewhere I have no idea what
these talking about but I'll check it
out anyway we'll check it for you guys
because I do have the seamoth and we are
gonna explore with it but next up is
ii-i'd on gaming who said good job not
cheating your subnautica series is much
more enjoyable so thank you everybody
for joining me thank you everybody wrote
on the walls but also ah it's [ __ ]
night okay but I've got something else
that I want to show you guys it's my
boys it's my baby boo [ __ ] it's it's my
baby boys it's a [ __ ] goddamnit sorry
yawn wait no don't leave me I know I
left you for like six months but I'm a
good dad I swear Geoffrey Billy samurais
and Marshall it's mum sweet baby boys
who I've already put to work because
they built my
there they built my seamoth and don't
ignore the fact that it's time to broken
I uh I got in a bit of a tizzy and I got
in a few accidents here and there and it
kind of got [ __ ] up don't worry about
that that's not important I am a good
seamoth driver ah so that pretty much
catches you up to everything that I've
got but the other thing that I do have
is I do have Dimond I do have the
materials necessary well I don't think I
actually have the materials necessary
but I do have materials that could be
necessary to build the laser cutter
which means that I can go back into the
Aurora and open up the prawn room and
hopefully get a prawn suit now I don't
know if I can do that just yet but I can
get the materials necessary for the
laser cutter so I gotta find out what
the materials are for a laser cutter
because I don't frickin remember it and
I have to drink I am out of water
frack I had supplies I had a bunch and
they're not here anymore because that's
stupid and dumb laughs okay so tools no
tools
I need the laser cutter which just needs
a battery and titanium which I think I
have that no I used every last drop um I
know there it is okay we're okay
everything's fine I got titanium and
everything is gonna be hunky-dory
I also have the battery in here dead
ones perfect dad is just as good as
alive in my opinion yes ah so I got
everything that I needed for that and it
is night unfortunately but that's okay
because that's not a deterrent for me
but what is a deterrent is failed
recordings and all I know is that this
recording I failed to but either way I'm
gonna push the saltiness out of a brain
because we got new stuff to explore now
we got some Reaper leviathans to deter
from eating our faces off and hopefully
it's not gonna be
too bad I know I'm running low on water
but I think then I hit a fish how come I
keep getting my freakin seamoth all
smacked up and I can't stop smacking it
up because it can't stop smacking fish
hi nice ass that was a little too close
for comfort
also I figured out a way to open up at
this is not important but there was a
little derelict thing that was blown off
the aurora but i found a way to open up
so god damn it what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] now let's drop us [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
get off get off I hate you my ass dive
[ __ ] you god damn it am i okay
I'm right about to run out of energy
yeah [ __ ]
god damn it is going swimmingly terrible
ah [ __ ] my seamoth all right well I'm
limped under the ship now oh don't come
after me
I thought I saw something in the
darkness okay I think I'm okay you think
I got a freakin freakin repair tool here
god damn it this episode is off to a
wondrous start I'm so happy all right
good news guys it's about to turn day
which is good very good actually I'm out
of energy I need to replace my goddamn
Power Cell okay it okay there we go God
knew on good thing I got tons of these I
mean he actually really is a good thing
that I got tons of these because they
require a lot of material and I do know
one spend time farming up my power sales
what's even better about is as soon as I
find the moon
plan which I don't even know where that
is anymore but as soon as I find that
I'll be able to do whatever it is I need
to do to be able to charge my seamoth
over and over and over again but first
off I need to get back in this Aurora I
need to get things in order
little uns but a humdinger of day I know
I'm not even close to done yet but I'm
going back man why can't I run over one
of those things
[ __ ] the think they're better than me
huh
just cuz you have stuff and things and a
life and friends and people that love
you and care about you well I have
nothing all the Reaper leviathans that
ate up my entire family abalone also
it's kind of funny I did find these logs
I don't have much time to look over him
but there was these funny logs that came
by Oh removed why was that removed I
don't know anyway it was like hey the
seamoth is a submersible fast safe mode
of transport Wow to continue to meet
your recommended weekly exercise
swimming is a fantastic goal a thing for
your gluts and endorphins and then
immediately after you get in your
seamoth it's like congratulations
survivor you have just exceeded your
weekly exercise quotient by 500% yay
data indicates that swimming was your
favorite activity be sure to vary your
routine for uniform muscle development I
know it's [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
there was this weird thing I don't even
remember where this was but it said
detecting massive energy signature in
the region
cannot identify and I don't know where
that was exactly because I think it was
on the way to the second island but then
again on the island I didn't see
anything I'll go back there and confirm
it with you like I really didn't see
anything if like Michael atlas said
there was a big-ass alien temple on one
of the islands and then I got that
message I was like oh maybe there's
something on here but I found absolutely
nothing and then this next one which was
a little [ __ ] after I got a diamond
that said remember the materials to
gather of the property of the Altair
corporation used to these resources for
survival is sanction but you will be
liable to reimburse the full market
price
your current bill stands it taking
hundred fifty eight thousand credits so
it's good news that as soon as I get
rescued if I do and if I don't die by
some sort horrible Reaper - then I will
be put in massive amounts of debt and
then crippled for life so I might as
well just keep living on this island
forever without my friends and family
because apparently something doesn't
want us to be here anyway so while we
even bother with planet is firmer necked
I mean plentiful and resources and all
that but the planet is Harbor knocked it
but it did it almost got it
almost got it almost got a BAM oh it's
me markiplier here anybody here anybody
home data pod this is something that I
definitely didn't see from Huggins -
Wilson you're telling me during these
last 13 months you never took a ride on
the outside now you've got yourself an
insider in robotics
well plane we've plane got nothing to do
until we get star side and start work on
the gate you want to get your hands on
with a mech and taste the stars you've
only got to say I've got a righteous
prawn suit here with your name on it you
don't know what power feels like until
you've crushed an asteroid with your
bare heavily mechanically augmented
hands okay that sounds cool I want that
can I have that all right search and
rescue crew the Mongolian vessel did
Gossie area day arm huh a Mongolian
vessel the de Ghazi disappeared almost a
decade ago corporate insurance has
purchased passage for the Aurora for
emissary Kassar and your orders are to
afford them every reasonable facility to
locate and if appropriate retrieve the
de Gossie crew members without
compromising the primary mission I am
about to drown okay see the aurora is
due to perform a gravity slingshot
maneuver around planet for 546 be
approximately 13 months post launch so
bring the ship within range of the de
gosse's last-known position the Gossie
crew manifesto has been distributed to
senior employees in a separate data
package so the de Gossie was actually
the ship that those people on the the
floating island were
talking about that's where they are from
I believe anyway I may be mistaken about
that but I'm pretty sure that was their
ship and if so they are all dead
and no one will save them now because I
and perfect water yes this game goth
provide my [ __ ] recording duck not
but this doth all right what have we got
here
I expected this to just keep kind of a
room okay oh I need the repair - huh
good thing I got both not just one or
the other for me ah man lovely how that
magically looks like an erection but
that's okay how about ski oh nice I like
it I like it a lot I like it the laws
this school so I see prom suits up there
but I don't know if I'm gonna be able to
do anything about that power self
perfect I get a lot of those see a lot
of upgrade consoles that's on fire am I
supposed to be putting this stuff out
can I just dump water on it from over
here
that looks almost intact can you
yes I can I'm gonna get a prawn suit I
mean not this episode but I'm gonna get
a prawn suit hmm then I'm gonna finally
be able to mine up those big bunches of
resources that are just on - OH
so there's one more over there and then
I got to get one of these I get this one
is it a little too on fire is this one
too on fire not scannable that's a bunch
of [ __ ] I thought we lived in the
twenty whatever century we are in and
somehow I got to be able to get up there
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme it's
right there come on it's right there man
not being such a loser scan it scan it
come on scan it scan it it's right there
okay so maybe he doesn't want me to scan
that one that's okay I didn't need to so
I got to get over this stuff no hello I
did not think there would be space under
this looks like something that I could
easily get lost in and then die here I
go anyway kind of cool actually why
would they put all this stuff down here
that looks like it's navigatable unless
there was a reason to do so you know
what I mean
is there a reason oh my god there is oh
my god there is hello where am I hello
hi what is this
where am I oh I didn't get the last part
what is this Aurora t-minus six minutes
this is an emergency distress call
aurora is on collision course with
planet 4 5 for 16 sending all available
environmental data
please find survival solution
AHQ teeth
- any survivors of the starship Aurora
if you're hearing this we will do
everything in our power where you have a
rescue mission would take years to reach
you out there but we think we've got a
better solution ELT here are a HQ t
plazita we received your environmental
data and we've sent you a blueprint for
a specially designed ship we think we'll
be capable of breaking all but and
getting you back here is facing
we calculate which you can find the
records of materials and such will be
short to start it t + 8 hours
communications relay offline wait
ok that was talking about something the
Aurora was gonna send data for a ship
that could break orbit like a way to
actually escape is that what I heard
there I'm gonna come back to that in
just a second because I I got a little
sidetracked I didn't get the last cron
piece but that was really interesting
that was hard to find and I just cut
open a door that I'm gonna go through in
just a little bit but I I just need to
make sure that I'm actually got
everything that I need here before I
start moving on but that's like
fascinating what does that mean for me
though does that mean I get it or was
that a pre-recorded message for
something that came along before me you
know what I mean
it was something about requesting
environmental data but I don't know if I
gave it what it needed or I only
downloaded a message you know what I
mean so what's what here that's the big
question
living quarters goddammit I need one
more prawn piece I can't get a prawn
piece I'm not gonna be able to build a
prawn like 3 of 3 for I think yeah 3 of
4 so there's got to be a way to scan
either this and
I don't think that's true or thaton and
maybe that one's also on fire which is
also bad so I gotta find a way to go
over here Mart it vending machine can I
do that can I just get a bunch of food
out of that please I'm desperate I'm
tired of eating living fish let's see
including the extras and a counterfeit
operator's license no way the Mongols
gave up the D restricted data transfer
for just 3,000 it's called negotiation
you should have learnt it in school
didn't move to Altera till I was 16
negotiation classes younger
it looks like the Altera transfuser I
have at home what do you have if what do
you have a fuser at home for messing
around turning the neighbor's dog blue
that kind of thing well does your fuser
have these ridges on the side ridges
mean no Altera restrictions
I heard the Altera models more reliable
looks better too are you joking this is
the finest transfuser in the galaxy I
once found a diamond blade on Pandora
for less than a thousand that's just
that's barely 250 shy of Altera price
still that saving could have paid for
this trip well you paid less than 250 I
paid double bet okay I have no idea what
that was supposed to be I've no idea why
I read that oh but I can get a calm
whole poster okay man it literally is
living quarters where are all the dead
bodies again whoa bed yes
bad bad [ __ ] bad I was looking for
the bed forever the last time I played
this before I did a big reset before
there was a bunch of updates I was
looking for a [ __ ] band
well [ __ ] dude I don't need a wide band
I didn't need a narrow bed because I
don't have anybody to sleep
okay let's see listen I know I don't
have the right to make demands of you
but I need you to understand that I want
to change a relationship I hear what
you're saying and I'll respect it how
would you like to change it I would like
to reduce our contact hours how much
further can we do that to zero you're
dumping me I'm changing the terms of our
relationship is it still a relationship
if we don't see each other of a kind you
have so many expectations I feel you
just want to spend more time with those
guys on the leisure deck
I feel hostility in what you're saying
and that jealousy is a possessive
emotion why can't you be happy for I am
happy for you and I'm happy for the guys
on the leisure deck I'm just not happy
for me
this is why I want to change our
relationship Wow Wilson sounds like a
dick
I have no idea what Wilson was talking
about there's Wilson a robot does that
what I'm looking at here Kyle get a
bench egg I guess it's gotta be codes
for this some way then but where I'm not
on represent sure here that's so bizarre
that these things are just here I don't
know how to get in them just yet but I
hope to do so soon maybe there's some
more codes like over yonder way but I
still gotta get kind of frigging scan
this last prawn piece because there are
no other prawns anywhere else in this
game at least I imagine there's not
enough I need one more come on don't
leave me hanging oh come on be a friend
please okay maybe maybe that was all I
needed over here and maybe I actually do
need to go over this way oh well that's
handy thank you for the flashlight I
think that was kind of guiding my way
over this way so there's got to be like
one more prawn piece over here coz
there's just got to be like there's no
way there isn't because they wouldn't
just leave me hanging with one left so
they wanted me to come over this way and
they wanted me to go over through here I
still don't have the passcode at this
there's got to be something else here
one more glorious thing come on one more
databank corruption was detected in her
PDA your technology brute prints have
been updated good yes what I didn't do
anything what did you give me you didn't
give me [ __ ] ah nice apply spare pda's
lab next door to the data coil doors 6 4
8 3 so that's probably not this one
considering this one is already open
from the other side but 6 4 8 3 I do not
have a fire extinguisher [ __ ] do I I do
ok I do is there something up here that
I need please tell me there is because I
want it so badly oh god damn it I don't
have a goddamn propulsion cannon [ __ ]
[ __ ] but this is another way out of here
but I don't have the propulsion can I
need it but I mean I can go the other
way out but it would take me [ __ ]
forever
okay but six four eight three is that
the code that cannot be the code to this
one over here but it could be the code
to something else
what really fans god damn open already
god damn it it was already open it was a
big hole blasted in the back of it or
maybe that's maybe this was actually
supposed to be locked but uh for some
reason it was left unlocked okay but
that didn't help me at all because it
didn't give me the data like anything
for my data things god there's got to be
one more prong I can scan it's gonna be
there cannot be
there's gotta be Hey oh that was it
those it yes I couldn't scan through the
fire yes oh my god I've got the
blueprint for a prawn so I know oh my
god oh my god okay so I need aluminum
oxide crystal plasteel ingot uranium and
lubricant that might be a bit of a [ __ ]
but I can do that I can get the plasteel
and I can get the other things and I can
do all the things that I need to do I
just need to be able to do them this
Abdulla okay so anyway that's all the
time I got for this one I do have the
prawn suit in the next episode I'm gonna
go get the materials and build the prawn
suit that I can make that and then
hopefully utilize that to navigate the
deeper environments and also gather more
resources more quickly and it should be
a lot of fun and it should be very
useful to me so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down the comments below and if
you have any insightful information let
me know that as well as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
by
[Music]